Now the story of a young man teaches mathematics to the world
Radio News Or Spencer Michaels reported on the report
Salman Khan: If this is a quadratic equation
We try to find zeros in it
This voice that is far from the body is heard every day
By tens of thousands of students who have difficulties in mathematics
Whether in the United States or in the world.
Salman: What is the result of squared +4 +4
Well, this is a Q + 2 multiplied by Q +2
Salman Khan, 33, has recently quit his job
As an analyst to devote himself to unpaid work
Teaching Mathematics Online.
Salman: Welcome to the lecture basics of collection
I know what you think
These are cancers or cancer cells.
When investors provide mortgage-backed securities
He has published 1200 lessons on YouTube that appear online
Topics range from the basics of the collection and the book of Calucus advanced to science and financial sciences
All are free
He asked: Introduction to Trigonometry - This is where I teach people about trigonometric functions
This is one of the most popular videos.
It has been viewed 179,000 times
This is the "pocket" of the cosmos, the "contact".
Salman Khan lives in the Silicon Valley, California, with his wife who is suffering from pneumonia at Stanford University and their new baby
The idea of ​​the Khan Academy was crystallized four years ago when one of his relatives knew how to convert kilograms to grams
A large number of American students face problems with mathematics;
Studies show they are lagging behind their counterparts in Asia
And Europe in mathematics and science.
With Khan's help, his relative got good grades in mathematics
Eventually he got a new career exploiting feelings of concern around the world.
He records his lessons now from a converted cupboard in the back of his bedroom.
And never expose his face or body
They feel as if there is a sound in their heads
And to watch it
You feel there was someone above your shoulder and talking with your ears
Reversing the fact that there is a teacher standing on a patient at a distance from you
I am sorry for my lesson with cough
But now I want to continue with 45-45-90 Triangles.
Although he is not the first person to teach online
His simple operations attracted more attention than most university sites, and his fame has spread
The Castilla School in Paolo Alto invited Khan to speak to the students
He contacted the students' body directly
Tell me what you do not know
Divide decimal numbers still difficult on some
If dividing decimal numbers is difficult for you, you are not alone
The feature of decimal numbers is one of the things that nobody would like to admit that they forget how to solve them.
It ripens pride in its expanding online audience
There are increasing numbers of viewers
The number is now 100,000 per month and 40,000 per day.
Reporter: The concept of short, repetitive lessons was attracted by freshman sophomore junior Brigitte
Which admitted that it had encountered a problem with seventh-grade algebra.
I think the teachers are good but they can not come up with a style that is perfect for everyone
But I like the concept of knowing something in class
Then I can press Stop or Return
In fact get a deeper understanding.
Shy students who do not ask questions in class can benefit more from Khan's videos
Says Kimberly Cap, who teaches mathematics in Castalia
His lessons are not an alternative to class
I do not imagine that there is a perfect alternative to the work we do
And the quality of the dialogue between students and teachers.
But Khan believes classrooms and classrooms may have their limits
Originally, he did short lessons because of the limitations of YouTube
Now he believes that the shorter the better
Some researchers have told me that you are not aware
Ten minutes - we have done studies on how long a person can maintain a high concentration
Anything more than ten minutes may lose your focus
I thought we all had this experience when we sat in college
Where you can be with a professor for about ten or fifteen minutes, and then lose concentration
Many math students agree with this view
I talked through the internet with Cody Woodward in Anchorage, Alaska,
Which uses Khan's lessons in college.
You helped me very, very much
I raised my grades in mathematics
I learned a lot too.
Online education, be Khan Academy, or registered university lectures
It is possible to revolutionize education in distant places in the Third World
Access to quality education is often not available
This is hoped, a software programmer at Cisco
He and his colleagues volunteer in a "possible world" and work on their holidays
They bring education to Africa and India for beginners
When Neil and Megha Khan traveled to Ethiopia
They found thousands of new computers sitting without work
Because she could not connect to the Internet, so she could not get instructions online.
Neil Satisfied: It's great that many of these resources are put on a single local server
So that we can bring it to universities, colleges and social centers
We arrived through the Khan Academy,
We contacted him by e-mail and asked him if we could reproduce some of the material on our servers
He was very willing to help us
Jain Mega: You'll be surprised at how fast children learn these things
So they are not curious about them
They have heard of it and are happy to use it
For Khan, the teaching of mathematics, science and finance is only the beginning.
He is willing to expand his own YouTube network to include anything he knows
I want to do everything, I want to work history, I want to work rules, and I want to work every subject
So far, except for some ad imports, he is donating his time and equipment
It is a one-man process.
But it has grown substantially, it will begin to seek external support to maintain the growth of the Academy